une usine de lieux désaffectés pour un
anniversaire c'est le cadre symboles
choisis par où va corse pour fêter des
années d'activité au bator se regroupe
une cinquantaine de vignerons qui
produisent des vins d'appellation
d'origine contrôlée
le choix de porto rico n'est pas fortuit
la cité du sel est l'une des capitales
touristique de nuit torride pour nous
c'est un très bon moyen de faire
connaître nos vins et de fait remporté
la bonne image de l'augmentation
qualitative de novembre vers l'extérieur
objectif de cette vitrine de la
viticulture corse associer les vins de
qualité aux produits du terroir une
opération parfaitement réussie qui sera
renouvelé lors des foires expositions
sur le continent et à l'étranger les
visiteurs ont pu apprécier le résultat
d'une politique de qualité mené depuis
dix ans par où va corse
en amont de cette politique la
restructuration du vignoble par
l'arrachage des vignes spéculative
remplacé par les cépages locaux
stabiliser aujourd'hui à dix mille
hectares le vignoble corse s'oriente
vers des vins d'appellation des
campagnes de promotions permettent ainsi
de faire connaître ses nouveaux produits
de tabac que je connais que j'aime bien
alors je sais pas s'ils sont tous
représentés ici gens découvrent la joie
d'en découvrir un la demande de toi tu
as signé gucci
et puis sinon
un jeu précis là que je vois ici qui est
la cuvée du président j'aime beaucoup
en fait tu là pour ça c'est pour faire
mon éducation
c'est un
une visite initiatique d'ailleurs je ne
bois que qu'à la tombée de la nuit comme
les vampires qui sortent de leurs
cercueils
je viens goûter le vin
oh